we are so excited this week and  especially especially tonight  I hate this I hate this everywhere you  go in Sandy yet you to see these East  Cooter's just lying around you know Andy  I know they just drop them anywhere it's  really annoying what kind of person does  something like this it's just annoying  and it's inconsiderate it's just a rude  thing to do  [Applause]  sorry wait a minute Norman do you have  do you have time to just hang out maybe  talk about the walking dead for a second  [Music]  no I have a My Little Pony panel I guess  ah got it  hi guys all right  [Applause]  Frenship a great show tonight the cast  the predator starring keegan-michael key  sterling K Brown Thomas Jane  Trevon teh road  [Applause]  Jake Busey  director shan-pak  you  [Music]  you